look at your Banky now look at mine now
look at your Banky now back to mine
sadly it doesn't look like mine but it
could if you join School come with me
where are you you're at a party but not
just any party you're a party and you
get to decide who's invited you can come
in my dear you cannot give me a and
because it's your party it can be free
or it can be paid it's up to you and
you're talking about whatever you want
to talk about because it's your party
learning and having fun
but don't believe me look at these
numbers this is the real leaderboard
from last month and sure I could talk
about Bill who's making $62,000 a month
helping people bookkeep better or Jamie
helping women invest making $41,000 a
month but what about the average school
Community well the average paid
Community makes
$1,360 per month how about them
apples what's that the ticket to the
thing that you've always wanted to go to
my headquarters here in Vegas become one
of the top 10 communities and you can
fly out whoop over there the ticket is
now a torch no it's an engagement ring
to the business of your dreams so that
you can marry it forever because one out
of two businesses on school create money
online anything is possible on school
click the link to start for free I'm on
a horse
[Music]